una declaración y tres instrumentos
alcanzados por consenso los 22 países
firmantes de la cumbre iberoamericana
número 28 aprobaron el sábado una carta
medioambiental una carta de principios y
derechos en los entornos digitales y un
plan para la seguridad alimentaria no
hubo un acuerdo para producir un
documento sobre la necesidad de una
nueva arquitectura financiera pero en la
declaración final se dijo imprescindible
contar con un sistema financiero
internacional más justo e inclusivo en
materia ambiental se firmó una carta que
pretende hacer frente a los desafíos del
cambio climático como la pérdida de
biodiversidad la contaminación y la
escasez de recursos hídricos en una
región constantemente golpeada por
sequías incendios inundaciones y el
deshielo de glaciares
esas proyecciones que hacen los
científicos
si no se hace nada
Hace de buena parte de este espacio
geográfico que aquí se reúne un lugar
inhabilitado en la tierra para el año
2070 la denominada ruta crítica para
alcanzar una seguridad alimentaria
incluyente y sostenible plantea medidas
para contrarrestar el impacto de la
guerra en Ucrania y otras crisis sobre
la producción agrícola en un contexto
donde la falta de acceso a alimentos
afecta a más de 250 millones de
latinoamericanos según la FAO también se
firmó una carta de principios y derechos
en entornos digitales que busca
garantizar el acceso de tecnologías a
personas con menos recursos así como
reducir la brecha digital en las zonas
más apartadas los asistentes declararon
su profunda preocupación por la
situación en Haití y se comprometieron a
tratar la crisis de gobernabilidad en el
país
Esa es la forma la comunidad
internacional
no que sigue esa situación en Haití y
todos los días con esas bandas lo que
hay es violaciones y más violaciones a
todos los derechos humanos y violaciones
también
a la integridad de la dignidad de las
pobres Ecuador tomó por primera vez la
presidencia pro tempore de la cumbre
número 29 que se celebrará en Quito en
noviembre de 2024